[Music]
I'm coming home
I just heard I'm loving that we're
getting even more eyes from the UK
thanks to Megan and Harry have you met
him as you come to set yet no I've not
met him no no what are the chances we
could get that's like a workplace you
would want to come to a workplace that's
not fit whoever thinks TV sets are cool
I got that call what are the chances we
could get it Harry a cameo on suits this
season I'll work on it yeah yeah but
I'll put in the hours
how cool is that very super easy and
uncomplicated you know completely you
don't know half of it how nice is it
though to see Megan so happy in a
personal life I'm so you know Megan and
I have been such good friends and for
years now and to see her so happy it's
it's great she's super excited and you
know we don't talk about it ever it is
you know the same way that I don't talk
about my personal life at work noted we
just don't bring that into the space
there's too much to do but super happy
for her and she's been such a pro and
the season is going so well so yeah it's
very very very happy for
[Music]
you